-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight,
and now we're going
to get to the news.
The annual New York City
St. Patrick's Day parade
was held today after being
canceled for two years
because of the coronavirus
pandemic.
Of course, they've had
to update the buttons.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden is set
to speak tomorrow
with Chinese President
Xi Jinping, and Biden is all set
to remind China
why they need us.
[ Laughter ]
Netflix announced yesterday
that the political satire show
"Servant of the People"
that stars
Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelenskyy
will return to the platform.
And they're also taking down
Putin's standup special.
[ Laughter ]
[ Russian accent ] Yeah, so just
broke up with girlfriend.
Feel bad.
So I bought her a trip
to Siberia.
This guy knows
what I'm talking about.
[ Normal voice ] President Biden
announced yesterday
that the U.S. will provide a new
assistance package for Ukraine,
which includes 800
anti-aircraft systems.
We're giving them the best
anti-aircraft system we have --
drunk passengers.
[ Laughter ]
[ Slurring ]
I'm not wearing a mask.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] A cargo ship
named "Ever Forward" is stuck
in Maryland's Chesapeake Bay
after running
aground on a sandbar.
And they're really rolling
the dice by sending
the "Never Sinks" to save it.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview
with Bloomberg,
a sanctioned Russian billionaire
said that he now has to live on
$3,300 per month.
That's weird.
They're making him
teach high school?
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience groans ]
Alright. [ Mutters ]
[ Laughter ]
Officials in Spain
recently impounded
a third superyacht
that's believed
to belong to a Russian oligarch,
mostly because they're not
very creative
with their boat names.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Pennsylvania
Senate hopeful Dr. Mehmet Oz
said yesterday that he would
renounce his
dual Turkish citizenship
if he gets election --
elected, excuse me.
No word yet on when
he'll renounce
the title of doctor.
[ Laughter ]
Transportation officials
in New York yesterday announced
plans to raise the flat fee
for a taxi
between J.F.K. Airport
in Manhattan to $65.
That's crazy!
That's almost $15 an hour.
[ Laughter ]
We mathed them.
We fully mathed them.
That's on us.
[ Laughter ]
We didn't even give them pens
and paper or anything.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, tomorrow is
National Awkward Moments Day.
This news first reported
by the guy who was
actually waving to the person
behind you.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.